the VHS series is now a trilogy with VHS
viral which came out on VOD today ahead
of its November 21st release date in
theaters and I checked it out for you
guys if you haven't been following the
previous two VHS films well they
basically are as a bunch of anthologies
in which people watch really creepy VHS
tapes and clever filmmakers can come in
and make their own short film to be
included in this anthology of horror I
actually enjoyed VHS 1 & 2 quite a bit
and even bought them on blu-ray so I was
actually excited to see what this new
film brought to the table because it
takes it in a different direction where
the previous two films were about
characters discovering VHS tapes in a
house watching them and they were just
really creepy this one does not have
that structure at all I suppose it's
more about teenagers who are trying to
film viral videos and stuff happens
while they're doing that not only is VHS
viral the most disappointing movie I've
seen all year it's the most maddening
this film is populated with the dumbest
most idiotic characters that you cannot
stand to watch more than a couple
minutes and I watched them for 77
minutes because as soon as the credits
start in this movie I checked the time
and it was 77 minutes long and I paid
$12 to watch this movie $12 for 77
minutes come on but whatever that's
besides the point let's talk about the
filmmaking in this movie the film is a
very forced message about the fact that
teenagers and young people are becoming
obsessed with the internet that viral
marketing campaigns and videos of
horrible things happening that get tons
of views is a terrible thing I agree
with all of that but it's such a forced
message and the way the filmmakers go
about trying to tell this tale is so
rushed and so jumbled that the message
not only becomes a gigantic blur but the
film is in conflict with itself because
there is a short film in this one that I
could not stand in fact when it ended I
actually stood up and said this
movie I'm done with this movie and I
actually had to sit and recollect my
thoughts for a while before I press play
again because it's one of the most
maddening things I've ever seen in a
movie it's basically a bunch of skater
kids who are the most annoying rude
people they're like 16 they're doing
drugs they're carrying around guns they
go to Mexico
they light fireworks and throw them at
people and then they spend an entire
five minutes just shooting Mexican
monster people and it was the most
annoying thing I've seen in a movie all
year I don't want to spoil it for you in
case you are interested in seeing this
movie but the way it ended was such a
cop-out don't waste your time the first
two shorts are better than that there's
one about a magician and one about a
parallel universe but my problem with
those is that none of it actually really
relates to the central message of the
film that they're trying to create
similar to the first two films while we
get these very shorts there are these
inter spliced actual stories happening
in the real world that continue
throughout the film and it's an
ice-cream truck that's emitting some
kind of signal that makes people go nuts
is there an explanation for that
no there's a ton of stuff that happened
in the first two VHS movies that were
never explained in fact in my original
review I said sometimes in a movie when
things aren't explained it makes it more
scary more frightening but in this movie
just felt like a rushed lazy and Cha
Polly edited excuse to make another one
of these so they can have a trilogy and
it's just going to become another saw
franchise what happened to the
inventiveness of the first two films
particularly the second one the director
of the raid and the raid - had a short
in the second one where has this
ingenuity gone what once was a really
cool idea for a franchise that was able
to showcase creativity and different
directors talents has become a garbage
can for the most crappy ideas I've ever
seen in a found footage movie in quite
some time
this film was so lazy that it even
reused shots from the previous films
including images of the succubus girl
from the first VHS and at the end of the
film there's images from the second film
playing on the television seemingly
setting up some weird universe in which
this all took place in one thing and it
doesn't explain it but if you actually
think about that it makes no sense at
all I am very disappointed in VHS viral
it is nowhere near as good as the
previous two it wasn't even scary there
wasn't a single moment in this movie
that scared me but there were a plenty
that I laughed at how terribly filmed it
was it is a horrible sequel definitely
don't check out VHS viral I'm gonna give
it an F the creativity was gone there
was only a couple cool moments and it
contains some of the most maddening
characters I've ever seen in a film and
it is certainly not worth the money
they're charging on VOD for such a short
movie definitely avoid this one guys
especially if you're a fan of the first
two like I am I'm very disappointed in
this guys what are your thoughts in the
VHS films and if you have seen VHS viral
let me know what you thought of it below
and as always thank you so much for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes